and then we get to this door and then
they
speak some kurdish and then i go
upstairs
and it's a bar and everyone in there is
chinese
what the what i'm like what what's going
and i was like
no did you i was like hey i'm not
chinese like oh that's why i brought you
i thought you
you could you you know them or something
that's [ __ ] funny dude
i'm like wait there's a chinese bar in
the middle of iraq
you come in they're like welcome yeah yo
chinese entrepreneurship is like
in five four three two one
annyeonghaseyo everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain
podcast we have one of our favorite
guests here the new favorite guest
is ed park the other one
the other one cheers ed park vp check
cheers cheers
people still love uh edric park too but
we're just mixing it up
too so funny that he called
he already called himself ed too so i'm
like i'm alright automatically
so one of the things that people wanted
us to talk about on this podcast which
you know there's a lot of
glancing stories throughout the podcast
that i've talked about when it came to
growing up in a korean church ed and i
so if you guys don't know there's a lot
of heavy like korean christian
communities
throughout the united states right and
something very unique that i didn't know
until i met ed
is that there is a substantial huge
uh korean christian population in
seattle i had no idea
because sacramento's korean population
is relatively small but
you know we somehow just find each other
and that's usually through church
yeah so i think uh we were well you were
like i guess everyone wants to talk
about church stories but we're like
where do we start yeah it's like okay
let's go
to the late 19th century
i mean like like what's it like uh
the philippines and uh japan and all of
them they got like
dutch catholics and whatever yeah and
like the spanish inquisition
but for koreans we got american
presbyterians
yeah if you notice everyone's
presbyterian yeah i might
the church that i grew up when was a
presbyterian church right the very first
korean chur
uh church in korea apparently is a
presbyterian church oh wow
and so everyone even if you have friends
that went to a baptist church they're
running it like presbyterians yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah which pretty much
uh presbyterian is uh
it's a democratic church system where
the
speaking pastor is just seen as like a
teacher
but he doesn't really have the power
right um
and that's why there's all these elders
chango news
yeah right from every district of where
they live in
yeah right and then they all vote
together who's the elder representing
their district
and then those elders represent the
congregation yep
and then they make votes right and then
so
that's why i get korean church gets so
political
and so rowdy it's so easy just to
you know you know now that you say that
i look at this
recent election and i'm like it's a
korean church
it really is though it gets that's
political yeah people start doing
conniving [ __ ]
they're they're trying to like butter
other people up to make sure that they
stay in power within the church
which is such an odd thing that i would
witness because we would have election
days like once a year where you vote for
that eldership
and some of those ajishi's man they
start walking around
super pious and like you know helping
people get their food and volunteering
and [ __ ] until they get their vote
then they walk around with their hands
behind their back and their nose in the
air
you know like so uh
so korean christianity is very
presbyterian
that's why it's very political too and
that obviously followed us so they had a
huge quote
like revival 1911 i think that's what it
is
and um where christianity just blew up
all over korea
and so that's why a lot of us immigrants
and our parents were all presbyterian
that's so interesting because
my dad told me this uh my dad
got his education because he went to
like one of those
korean christian schools in south korea
yeah
and that's how his introduction into
christianity happened because my family
was buddhist before
right so we had like our own shrines and
like
little temples that our family was
affiliated with or owned in korea
and then my dad threw that presbyterian
church missionary work
he became christian yeah like a lot of
like korean history our religion history
is obviously buddhist but the other one
culturally is shamanistic right where
you turn to animals and [ __ ] yeah right
which is so dope
right what was the one there was the
korean film about that what was it uh
uh it was it was like a slight horror
film but it you see the old
old religion the shamanism yeah yeah
yeah so
within that like that's when the
missionaries came like because there's
so many different gods they're like no
there's
hananim that's where there's one guy
yeah
and that's where that comes from so for
us
when koreans started coming to uh
america to
set up a church right um so what i found
out
um a while ago when our church came up
with a yearbook
apparently our church is the first
korean church in washington state
that oh really yeah so my mom when she
immigrated there went to youth group
at the church i grew up in and that's
why
our church was is pretty big for korean
church out there in tacoma
because it was the first one that's why
districts reach out all the way to
seattle
bellevue pop renton like federal way
holy [ __ ] all these other cities in
washington
with koreans in them you know um
so our church was pretty big because of
its like it's like almost 50 years old
now which is crazy wow that's really old
yeah um
it's all the elders were my like mom's
like
old buzz and onions and stuff it's so
weird the church dynamic was so odd
i think when when you're kind of
introduced to religion as a kid you go
because your parents go right and then
at a certain point when you reach an age
you have to decide whether you want to
be a part of this or not
right right uh and usually what happens
is like you're fr you grew up with these
people they are your friends
and that becomes like your identity
right because you guys all grew up in
this soul system and so you want to stay
in it because your friends are in it too
right
you know so it's it's your family
identity it's your your your social
identity it's everything to you
so my weird experience was i [ __ ]
hated church as a kid
i was this little [ __ ] that hate you
know when you were a kid
and you go to vbs which is vacation
bible school
there would be some of the older
classmates they would run the programs
and all the other stuff
i i literally have my vbs like little
sticker thing with my picture on it
and i'm scowling like into the camera
because they're telling me to make
i'm against the wall and i'm squinting
with my eyes super hard like [ __ ] you i
don't want to be here
because i i just there's something about
me where i just didn't like doing group
activities right so if it was like
everybody was raising their hands i'm
just in there like why
why do i have to do this and then people
would get mad at me they would get
[ __ ] mad at me they're like oh you're
you're not down for christ
you ain't down for christ you think
you're too cool for christ he's like no
i just don't want to do this
you know i i think i was caught up in
that because i love
church yeah my situation because i hated
being at school on the weekdays
i'd always come to the and hang out in
tacoma for the
weekends and i just [ __ ]
loved being there but then it was also
like i
also caused a lot of trouble because
i don't know it was just like wild
teenage kids too but
um man
ray i hope you edit this part because i
lost my train of thought
but you know some of the stuff that
people want to talk about i know you
guys want to get into the juicy details
but
this background is super important to
understand the dynamic of a korean
church
because culture korean culture and that
and the christian religion would mix
together super hard
which made the environment in a korean
church awkward like you don't
you don't understand what these rules
are right because sometimes it's like oh
these
christian rules apply but the korean
cultures here stands on top first oh my
gosh
i never understood like okay well what's
the hierarchy here what
what rules are we following by right and
there would be so much the church
dynamic was interesting too because
i think everybody from an outside
perspective you thought that everybody
who went to a church are these perfect
human beings right
right when really it's just a bunch of
trash ass people right you know that
needs saving that come together
so you see a lot of trash behavior so
and
dude i i've told this uh
let's here's here's one segment that we
could start off right and we were just
talking about it before on the podcast
the idea of a chastity ring was the
dumbest [ __ ] thing
i've ever seen in my [ __ ] life
because nobody that i knew that had a
[ __ ] chastity ring at church
kept their virginity it's like well i
thought about a lot too but like
especially koreans
because what you're saying earlier is we
mix confucianism
with christianity yeah so it's like
everything is based off fear
everything you're not we're not doing
anything because we love jesus we're
doing it because we're scared
and so what they're trying to hide a lot
like when you say that to me is like
koreans are horny as hell yeah
like i i know we are it's like i'm not
the only one right
why am i so [ __ ] dude half the dudes
in the youth group only went to church
because they wanted to [ __ ] one of the
girls right
that's that's what the funniest thing is
too is when uh
i used to love this moment where we're
we have our own youth group right but
then there's a new girl that comes in
all the guys stop and they look at the
new girl because they're like
this is somebody new in the pool that we
could possibly date
and all the dudes would be super [ __ ]
nice and i hated this thing too where
it's like the church oppa they would
always try to do like the sleaziest
[ __ ] things to these younger girls
and it was so hard to watch
right so it would a church oppa if you
guys don't know is like the guy that
tries to spiritually guide
this younger girl right and what their
actual intention is is to [ __ ] her
and it was the most creepiest thing that
i would always see in korean churches
they
they see this girl she's trying to get
to know god but the guy is trying to
make sure that she knows god through his
dick
this girl would always be like and they
would find him through their vulnerable
moments
and they will reach he's like hey if you
ever need somebody to talk to you could
call me
you know i'm only like a phone call away
and then he would guide her help her
spiritually and the next thing you know
she's over at his house
and he tries and he tries to [ __ ] and
i'm like that's the most sleaziest thing
you could do i hated that [ __ ] and these
guys by the way the reason why i [ __ ]
hate them is because
they're losers and they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] because the only way they can
get a girl to talk to is one when
they're
beaten down they feel like they have
nothing left to lose
and they come in as their quote-unquote
spiritual savior and that's how they get
to them which makes you a
[ __ ] trash human being i [ __ ]
hated those guys i uh
when i was in college i was doing uh i
was a youth group teacher
and i was co-teaching with another dude
um the eighth grade and
this is so tough it's making my stomach
like
sink yeah this
okay because when you're telling it like
it's uh
do you know exactly why yeah yeah yeah
this it's the [ __ ] eighth grade and
this new girl comes and all of a sudden
my coat
my partner in this is attention
all's out like on this girl yeah and
i just have to be like hey man like cut
it out
yeah yeah dude like he's like no dude
it's nothing i actually knew when she
was in kindergarten
i'm like bro i'mma stab this guy i don't
even know who he is i'm gonna stab his
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] this guy and
[ __ ] starts getting weird where is just
like
where he's seeing her on the weekdays
he's picking her up and giving her rides
why yeah what what for what purpose do
you need that for
and then yeah someone said they
witnessed him kiss her
in the parking lot how old was he he was
20 you're 20.
what's going on in the [ __ ] that's a 13
year old
and yeah i put them in we put them in a
room you're like yo this isn't
cool you can't do this
and he's like i know what i'm doing
and i know you guys don't know and i
know what i'm doing
listen i've been raping girls just for
the past for the past six years
you [ __ ] so and uh eventually gets to a
point where you just
he quits and they start dating
where the [ __ ] is this girl's parents
exactly that's what's
so so to get to that point about
our area in tacoma
lower middle class lakewood exactly um
a lot of us when we were talking about
the church history uh
koreans went to church when in the 70s
and 80s because that's where all the
koreans were
yeah it's still how it technically works
now
yeah yeah like if you're you don't live
in l.a and there's a you don't have a
korea town you're gonna go to church
yeah
that's your korean town it's your korean
town yeah
you know and so um but also the
environment of where this church is
matters too and a lot of our kids
are uh neglected
uh parents are working um they ain't got
[ __ ] to do or whatever
and and it's just
yeah the system of vulnerability and
these [ __ ] just [ __ ] ass dudes
taking advantage of that what a [ __ ]
creep dude yeah that's that blows my
and you know what this i so my dad
my dad was one of the uh the church uh
deacons uh at the church that we used to
go to the church that i used to grow up
at right
and the the politics and emotions that
go
goes on between that kind of [ __ ] up a
lot of relationships within that
community right
so uh there was a dude that was a youth
group leader and you know we would do
these retreats and retreats are these
like spiritual retreats so we would go
out
we would praise god you know we get all
emotional open our hearts to each other
and [ __ ]
love retreats and then we have really
fun games we will [ __ ] around doing kids
yeah yeah skits all those [ __ ] we do
youtube videos right yeah
we always win skits yeah that's the only
started with these little [ __ ]
sketches i used to kill that [ __ ] um
this podcast is brought to you by better
help is there something interfering with
your happiness
or is preventing you from achieving your
goals my friends
i know i've been in that place and the
reason why is because i never really
focused on my
mental health now here's a couple of
things some of us out there might not be
comfortable
especially right now during this
pandemic to be going out and seeing a
therapist well there's also online help
and better help is here
to help you with your mental health it's
not a crisis line it's not self-help it
is professional counseling done securely
online this service by the way is
available for clients
worldwide betterhelp is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if
needed better help wants you to start
living a happier life today because you
deserve it my friends i have used online
counseling before and
the convenience is great and i got to
tell you ever since i started focusing
on my mental health
i have been so much happier let's get
rid of that stigma that people
don't need mental help for your health
you do need it
and there's nothing wrong with it and
better help is here to help you visit
betterhelp.com
genius that's better help and join over
one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help they
are recruiting additional counselors in
all 50 states
special offer for my genius brain
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com genius that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash genius today
but there was one of these guys who i've
talked about this guy in the podcast
before but i never told i don't think i
told this specific story but this dude
was
a trash bag he was an emotional trash
bag so
he kind of was once again
around this younger girl this girl was a
year younger than i was right
uh he at the time was just started going
to college i think out in davis
and he was one of the church leaders
within the group so
lo and behold during the retreat he
actually [ __ ] her
at the retreat so they snuck off
somewhere you know we have our separate
cabins for guys and girls
they snuck off and he [ __ ] hooked up
with her at the retreat
so my dad caught wind of this because
obviously people are talking people are
upset they're pissed off
right but before it can get to the other
deacons that
kid the the college person was his dad
was a deacon and my dad was a dean as
well
so my dad took him aside and had a
conversation with him i did tell the
story
but he took him aside and uh had a
conversation with them and he just
started going off on my dad he was like
what the [ __ ]
you know you you're like how dare you
come up to me my dad's like hold on a
second
i'm telling you this personally before
it gets to you and rumors start
so you need to go talk to your son and
figure this stuff out first
right so lo and behold this guy is like
in denial and i'm by the way this
[ __ ] lives across the street
from me
right and i when when i heard he went
off on my dad i was like in my mind i'm
gonna
[ __ ] his son up and i'ma [ __ ] that guy
up too because my dad's trying to do you
a [ __ ] favor
and it turns out of course it's true
yeah you know it's true the guy gets
he doesn't get banished from church but
people know about him and everybody
started looking at that dude sideways
and because like these emotions are
involved he doesn't want to address the
situation and some of these korean
parents
they're so stupid like you guys your
children are not angels
like they're they're not as sweet as you
think that think they are you don't know
your kids
and a lot of asian parents don't know
their kids on that type of level
so they just think that these these
dogmatic
um ideals that i've been beaten into my
kids like this is who they are
but you don't know your kids at all a
lot of your kids were [ __ ] scumbags
and i had to deal with that [ __ ]
you know no i um
dealt with um there's a number a handful
of just these
older dudes taking advantage of these
young girls
and i don't know what the
[ __ ] like that's a i don't know why
that [ __ ]
keeps happening in churches it's just
church thing all across
right catholics have that problem it's
in the news all the time or whatever
and it's one of those things which makes
you just feel like
let me just distance from this [ __ ] now
like what the [ __ ]
it's it's like that that people kind of
everybody comes to church for different
reasons right and
we have this idea that we think that
everybody's the same but everybody's so
different
some people don't have the best
intentions when they come in they they
it's not that they're evil but they have
these bad tendencies and people kind of
glaze over it because they don't want to
stir the pot or or they don't want to
confront people
i'll tell you i think um church these
days are pretty
keen on that now especially the social
media people blow you up dude
yeah i remember my senior pastor
i love him too shout out to pastor sam i
love you
um some guy was uh
like mind you this is the senior pastor
of the korean church so he does the
main services yeah and we were missing
an
english ministry pastor he came in i
mean he's a princeton crowd
yeah and he would do the same sermon um
for us
in english while there was someone there
and um like i said there's a military
base
in in in tacoma and so people get
stationed there
and they look for church or whatever
this one dude
like first day there nobody knows who he
is
and he's sitting next to this girl and
then he puts his arm around there in the
middle of service
what the [ __ ] is this it's just some
[ __ ] guy his first time there yeah
and like yeah my
my senior pastor had like yeah just had
a word like straight up to his face
like like either you're coming here for
the right reason or you're getting out
or whatever so
um i think people's awareness of that is
like on high guard now because
people don't want that [ __ ] right yeah
but i'll tell you what
like um
sometimes like i went to
uh so okay i i hope you can edit this
better so i can
tell this story so uh
when i went back to washington uh i
didn't i felt super out of place at my
home church
you know i didn't really feel like like
everybody went on with their lives
they're different everyone's married
they have kids
and meanwhile i'm like 30 not married
yet or whatever
so i feel out of place and like
also people like to pressure you to get
married yeah
um so i went to another church
which is younger uh based like average
age being like
late college um so
i was like about maybe three years older
than the average person there
so uh they had a
a newcomers like bowling like get
together
so i was like yeah i haven't been
bullied of course korean churches and
bowling and volleyball are the two
biggest things you could ever do so
we're bowling and stuff and then
like a kid comes out like hey um
so why'd you want to you know join this
church
you know i'm like yeah i uh i don't know
i think i need a new setting
um i really really like the praise team
they're really good
uh this and that and he's like well i
mean like
you're like so much older than everyone
you know
just like what is this ageism in church
now
where i'm like like i don't know what
why i off the bat i almost felt
unwelcome yeah but i stuck it out
at least because um i know the people
there
and whatnot but after a while it was
just like
being the old guy in a church felt weird
like i'm only
at this point 30 31 32
um that's not that much of a difference
but yeah but because like we were saying
that confucianism embedded in us
yeah they can't help but keep looking at
me like this older guy
and like this guy that they have to
listen to
and this guy that they have to or
whatever even though i'm a nobody
yeah kind of thing and like the kids
would call me hyung and
whatever like which was cool and stuff
but then
it it put me at this like gap
where i couldn't even have like a closer
relationship with these people because
they
always want to distance themselves yeah
i don't know this is the age way
yeah that's where that korean cult it
was hard for me sometimes because i
even though like i was born in korea i
speak korean to my parents only
i i grew up in an area where there
weren't a lot of korean people so the
concept of calling somebody hung that
wasn't my brother
i wasn't having it you know and so when
dudes would come up and you know call me
young
first i'd be like no and they thought it
was super disrespectful it's like it's
not super disrespectful [ __ ]
we're in america but wait wait how big
were you when you were in like youth
this size yes so when those guys
communic yeah calling me home i get
beating
dude i got a beating i had a i had an
issue with that stuff too because i
didn't like the way some of these older
korean guys because they're so used to
that korean culture of
hyung ship like call me your hyung i get
and there's a lot of hazing and korean
churches that we can get into
purple nurples [ __ ] motorcycles
[ __ ] you up motorcycles you know
but the thing about that [ __ ] by the way
a motorcycle if you guys don't know is
where you grab somebody
by the ankles you stick your foot in the
middle of their [ __ ] choke
it doesn't hurt but it tickles and it
feels the it's like the worst
it hurts and it tickles at the same time
there's no yum young's will make it hurt
yeah so i i had a problem in church and
uh i didn't start really getting into
church until i got a little older
because when i was younger people would
try to send me all the time
yes and the weird thing is is like you
guys grow up in a nicer area
i did not grow up in nice area you don't
get to talk to me like that unless
you're gonna kill me like unless you're
gonna do something unless you're jumping
me into a [ __ ] gang
which i'm not about either you can't do
that and i remember there was this one
guy
which you know this guy interesting and
i think pretty sure he's a really nice
guy now
but he had a habit of thinking he was a
thug and he grew up in a nice area right
and he got
whatever he scrapped with a few people
back in the day right but he was three
years older than me but i'm about the
same height as him
you know and so i remember he came up to
me and told me to call him young
and i lit them i was like no and then he
was like you better call me hyung and he
slapped me upside my head
and i remember just that moment too he
slapped me upside my head and then i
looked around because my dad's a deacon
at this church
i can't do anything bad and he knows
that he knows that i can't act
up because i would get my [ __ ] ass
beat by my dad
and then you know maybe some other
deacons will wipe my ass too there's
this thing in like korean culture too
like you get a transfer weapon it
doesn't matter who your parents are
somebody will up your ass and it's okay
you know what the funny thing is because
we're koreans like there's so many
brawl stories at church so many five
stories there's
fight stories at church like even when i
was in elementary
oh dude your cousin got in a fight like
what what what and then i got older
and then that youth pastor was at a
different church and i was like
doing some ministry stuff with him he's
like oh i remember you or whatever right
yeah
and then he goes yeah um these
your cousin and this guy they're trying
to fight or whatever this is how korean
this [ __ ] is he goes
they all came to me and they were like
pastor pastor stop stop this right and
he went to them they're like scuffling
and he goes
you two should fight you guys fight each
other
but one of you have to die
because you're fighting because you're
fighting in god's house
that's what he said
this is so cur so you you mix korean
[ __ ] like crazy like uncontrollable
emotion with
a christianity
so even like um like probably there's a
lot of
koreans uh who have like a a youth
pastor used to be a gangster
too right i love those pastors the most
because
some of these pastors were so funny
because i don't think
they're trying to sometimes scare people
straight when some of these dudes don't
need to be scared straight and it's the
most horrific stories ever
and i see these kids mortified i'm like
i don't you're not in compton bro
you know like hey when i was your age i
used to kill people
and i'm like what are you doing why
would you
say that and so now i'm gonna believe in
god thank you
because you murdered people you see
these tattoos you know they would always
show their tattoos like
[ __ ] so one of the pastors
i was closest with um
so like uh he was in his 40s
and he became a new pastor so he was a
chunder like an
you know uh intern pastor youth pastor
but he's in his 40s
and it was because he spent a majority
of his life
as a gangster in kk yeah
which is a an og like gang
yeah um the funny thing is like
my whole life my mom would give me the
gang talk
right she's like don't join a gang don't
ever join a gang no matter what i'm like
um why am i going to join the game
you know it's because your dad wasn't a
gang yeah he was in kkk
i'm like no he wasn't on my oh my it was
not okay
yes in kkk
right and so this new youth pastor comes
he goes i was in a gang in koreatown
and we were called kk so i was like oh
[ __ ]
you know i went to my mom and i was like
was he kkk
no he was in kkk oh major kkk
you don't add the extra k that's a
different group of people this [ __ ]
youth pastor was in the same game as my
dad
that's so [ __ ] funny and they knew
each other from like the late 70s
and the early 80s in k town that's when
they
started yes when they started when like
the huge korean immigration started in
the 70s
and so the thing was oh so your dad's
from l.a
yeah yeah when he so the whole story my
dad was
uh adopted um
long-lost twin uh got split at birth
uh went to came here to america
uh grew up in k-town went to virgil you
know
on vermont and like i know that school
yeah that's that was where i used to
live
right around the corner yeah so like he
grew up here in america
you know and my dad at one point he told
me some stories
about like the wild [ __ ] they would do
like uh just fights and brawls and stuff
and this pastor when i came up to him i
was telling hey
um my mom told my dad's in kk too and he
was like what
who's your dad and
they linked them they became friends
because my dad got saved when he was
like 45
yeah you know after a whole bunch of
like life of crazy [ __ ] um
so they linked and like yeah they like
did wild [ __ ]
in the 70s so this used this guy told me
like
uh on korean independence day they'd go
to little tokyo
right him and the other kk guys and they
were serious about foosball
you know the table suckers what the [ __ ]
they had the gloves and everything all
right
they go to little tokyo on korean
independence day look for some japanese
kids at a ymca or whatever right let's
like let's do this put money on this
right and then he goes win or lose
we would beat them up to a pulp and then
we go
there
ymca neutral playing grounds we're gonna
[ __ ] up these japanese people and say
korean pride forever and then run away
got a [ __ ]
trash ass plan so that was my youth
pastor that's
hilarious dude so like
um so he understood like my
when i would act out and i would lose
control
or you know not have to do that like he
understood me the best a lot of people
didn't mesh with him well
um but he really understood me i think
very well and
which i really appreciated out of him
because like
um my younger sister was dating this kid
right
um so they're like in high school dating
whatever
and all my youngs were pushed like are
you going to beat this guy up
wait wait wait why right because he's
dating your sister you got to [ __ ] him
up
uh i'm not sure if that part comes yet
right yeah
and it's like even if he's a good guy
he's like yeah you got to beat him up
yeah
but he's a good guy they like each other
they care about each other no
no no you have to kill them well over
time they
ended things very in a very sour manner
and all my
friends they were bullying him
and saying oh it's gonna [ __ ] you up and
i'm like
why are you saying this like what are
you guys talking about and then so it
started
look it's just like a turn of events
this started [ __ ] with his head
so he started calling me out and calling
me a [ __ ] and that i'm not gonna do
anything
and he's like even if it if he beats me
up i'm just gonna
bleed all over him laugh and you say
wild stupid emo [ __ ] like what kind of
what is wrong with this kid right so
dude i wish you would stab me i'm gonna
ruin your white shirt you know hearts
get blood out of a white shirt
all right bro
you should have a lot of bleach
so getting to a point where i got to
talk to this kid
i finally got to talk to this kid and
even my tongues are pressuring me my
friends were like would you gonna do
anything
and so i found out i found out that he's
like hanging out at this uh
this beach park and there's like
i don't know about like 15 20 other kids
there with his friends
um at this point here's the thing i'm
20. yeah and he's 15.
you know and i'm like i gotta do
something i gotta do this because look
look
tony i'm still a young kid i'm still
feeling pressured that i gotta beat this
man of an oppa or well of course because
all your friends are
talking in your ear saying you have to
do this hyper machismo
older brother thing and come in and [ __ ]
somebody up to basically piss all over
his territory you know
and i mean it's hard too especially when
you're 20 and all your friends are
saying this [ __ ]
it makes you feel like you have to do
this stuff yeah it's like when it's like
when we're younger somebody goes you're
like i don't want to do that [ __ ] that
you all what i dare you
so you dare me but at the same time i
had to do something
yeah you know i called you a [ __ ] i had
to do something so
i i found him at the park
and then he's like i'm not going to say
he's rolling deep he's he's with another
youth group actually yeah
they're having like a men's outing and
he's and and
like a youth group outing and
i'm like hey i i catch him and he's like
oh [ __ ] like cause i found out where he
was
i'm coming i want to talk to you you
know
um but i as i'm talking to him i
start you know how it is like i started
adding
look man you said this and you said this
and you said dude
and then as i'm laying i'm kidding i'm
shaking
and before i know it i grabbed this
[ __ ] face and i shoved into the
ground
yeah right and my friends were there so
they held me and
i wanted to rip them apart and i'm like
like i should [ __ ] kill you
yeah you know and um then all
his friends come up and i with like
marshmallows on their stick like
hold on we're gonna make smarts what are
you doing
and it became this big thing where um
pretty much it came to this because my
friends were there with me
they were like look man you did his
younger sister dirty like
this is our younger sister too you know
with all my friends they all looked
after my sister too growing up
so they were pissed that's really why
it's just being a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
all i'm gonna say and
i said either we're gonna
let ed kick your ass or you're gonna
kiss his
her foot oh damn yeah
and we humiliated him we he opted to
kiss her foot that's [ __ ] nuts
and we made him get down on his knees
and kiss her feet
and i came back to church
and my pastor was waiting for me yeah
right
and he goes ed what'd you do and i was
like
i didn't beat him up and he gave me a
big fat hug
he goes i'm so proud of you man you know
me and your dad we would have
we would have messed them up man yeah we
would have messed him up and he goes i'm
proud of you
he's like yeah but you know i shoved his
face and made him kiss her
that's that's the work of the lord
that's how it ended but tell you what
like it didn't end for me there
yeah as those guys got older
and and they were coming they got they
turned 21
yeah and they're showing up at tiggs oh
my god
[ __ ] did they still held that up they
held that in
and here's the thing though you know
tiggs by the way
was this a korean bar that whenever i
went to seattle and you know it was
there too that we would just go drink
there all the time it's like a bunch of
korean people in there just
it's free flowing
over time like i held
like when i went back to church a lot of
people gave me [ __ ] yeah they really
shouldn't have done that
you know the actual christians yeah
not to take that away from pastor yeah
but um
but at the same time one dude i was like
they're giving me [ __ ] i'm like
you have younger sister man wouldn't you
do something
for her and he was no no she and i was
like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah like dude you wouldn't stand for
your sister and
and so there was this weird balance of
like i was constantly did i do something
right or wrong like
i couldn't tell is this christ like is
his brother like where do i find this
where do i draw this line and then i'm
like making excuses at least i didn't
[ __ ] him up though you know
but i made him like so
at one point i i
got into too much quarrels because some
guy who knew who
what i did to him would start some [ __ ]
they're still
angry about it yeah five years later so
what started happening for me though was
when i'd see those kids i'd bring them a
shot and be like hey man
i remember you were you were there you
know what i did and whatever i just want
to say
you know yeah hope you don't feel it and
and then they
they they give me a like mean mug as i
as i come up to them
and then they go all right you know
i feel like i should be mad at you but
thanks and they were like you know what
if i was him i probably deserve to get
my ass kicked or whatever and like
well they knew he would yeah you know i
mean we were both wrong
too you know but honestly where it's
it really started taking me where um
because it was regularly occurring
because those kid
kids witnessed what i did you know and
they were
really [ __ ] angry at me yeah you know
but i'm supposed to be this church guy
yeah you know this church leader and i
had put a stain on myself pretty much
yeah and yeah so
uh one guy it got really close to blows
and [ __ ] because he was coming in honor
of him and whatever
honor of him like here's the thing too
like korean dudes out there or just men
in general
put your [ __ ] ego aside man you have
any idea how
how stupid that concept is because i
gotta protect my homie's honor from
[ __ ] whatever four years ago who the
[ __ ] cares nobody cares
you know so but as it was going on
it really really drove me into this
crazy existential
crisis like am i really a christian yeah
was that very christian
something really [ __ ] up you know yeah
and um
that drove me into really really really
digging into
the bible and theology and reading all
these different books on doctrines and
different
ideas and whatever to the point where
i literally sold my things because i was
reading what does jesus want me to do
sell your possessions right so you went
to the deep end i want to deepen
you know because of like the like you
know
it's a story of like uh
youth and growing up or whatever but
then i was really like what the [ __ ] did
i do
you know am i a christian or am i not
what is christianity
so i started digging deep deep deep into
the word where i
sold all my stuff and i ended up
living in iraq for two months you were
in iraq for two months
yeah what the [ __ ] are we doing there
just living there
with like missionary workers yeah well
like okay
what is what does missionary work look
like to you like in youth group we go to
mexico for a week
and we come back yeah that's that was my
missionary yeah i like
him other people like i know a couple of
my friends who
really did hardcore missionary work
throughout uh when they were in
university or
college and they would be like in
mongolia for a month they would be
in um i heard japan was like the last
place you're allowed to go
yeah i i don't know why but that was
like the that's like hold on you gotta
go
you gotta go to guatemala first before
you go to japan i'm like really
i guess because from what was explained
to me was that they're hardcore
either atheist or they're super like
shinto so it's
it's like one of those places that you
don't go first not only that
japanese uh view on christianity
is little literally like a mental
disorder
oh really yes they look at christians as
like a mental disorder
oh wow that's why you've been like
trained
for years before you build it right so
yeah i um
i started digging in doctrine and wait
what the [ __ ] was iraq like
were you there for two months what the
yeah what the [ __ ] was that like
it was awesome dude really it was
[ __ ] awesome
i loved i was there in 2009 and
the thing is like because every summer
in youth group i'd go to mexico or
somewhere
and what are you doing you're singing
songs and doing like body worship
and and like you you just think about if
some people just showed up to you and
started singing these songs and dancing
you're like
the [ __ ] is wrong with you what's wrong
with you what are you doing you know
but yeah like um i
i pretty much became a monk where i was
like
this god is real or he's not yeah you
know and i'm
and i got to figure this shot if he's
really real and i was doubling down on
my faith
like time to go to iraq yeah and
it was pretty much this voice
in my head which was like just telling
me to just go to iraq go to iraq go to
iraq go to iraq
so i figured out which way to do it i
joined this organization called
ywam oh you are a part of wyoming dude
wyom is a huge
organization and i got stories about
wyoming too
they got problems
but um i i went with them uh
i didn't want to do you know what dts is
discipleship training yeah yeah yeah
yeah the three-month program i did that
um dug even deeper into the word in
theology
for the next and then after that i was
in iraq for two months where
i chilled there was no program no songs
to sing and dances to do yeah
i lived my life i went out there to the
bazaar
every day and just stood around and
people
jackie chan jackie
chan every day yo this is actually
real they've never seen an asian person
before they're live
so if you watch the that uh david chang
show
yeah uh where he travels around he was
with chris tegan when he was in morocco
and he said when he was walking around
you could hear people call him jackie
chan as he's walking around
which which you know people are like
that's racist but at the same time i'm
like damn jackie chan is a big star huh
that's what i learned in iraq yeah what
i learned in iraq and understood more
than anything is that jackie chan and
arnold schwarzenegger are the most
famous people in the world
it's
that was one of my like
cards of like getting to make
relationships with people
right because i'm not out there with a
pamphlet like do you know jesus they
might
you know something might happen to me
you know it's an entire field like it's
a theocracy they're run by like muslim
law
yeah you know so i have to be there and
make friends and so every day i'd go out
to the buzzer and just chill
you know go to the arcade just chill
somebody
somebody's like oh like do you speak
english
and because like they're learning
english and they want to they want to
interact
interact like practice come over to my
house for dinner so i'd go to the house
they bring their entire [ __ ] there'd
be like
30 people in a giant living room and
there's a giant carpet on the floor
and we just feast that's awesome awesome
and we
i stay with him for hours just talking
and then
one the one guy that speaks english with
translate and then we
here's the thing they want to talk about
jesus
you know wow because they're so curious
they're curious yeah
you know and you know what i wasn't out
there with my missionary suit yeah in my
badge and uh you know
i was just living my life and i was out
there teaching soccer with the kids
you know i was like you know how to play
soccer you know
i i was just living my life and hanging
out and somebody would want to bring me
over to dinner
and isn't that crazy though they know
they're like they'd be like
you're christian right so tell me about
jesus i'm like what what how do you know
he's like why else are you here yeah
like they're not stupid
you know you don't have to trick them
with something yeah [ __ ]
you know you know what's so interesting
and i think i love these type of
experiences too because
this goes back to that thought of what
we're fed
through media without actually being
as a human being going out there and
experiencing it for yourself yeah so we
have a thought of what people are how
they behave
and you know when even now because of 9
11
and everything that came out after that
i know better as a person because i've
traveled the world now
but when i hear iraq there's this weird
feeling that i have in my stomach
right because of the the oil wars
because of all this other stuff right
but you don't hear about these human
beings who are out there when you sit
there they look at you
i want to know more about you please
come into my home and share this meal
you don't have that here in the states
and so yeah we have a perspective these
people as if they're [ __ ]
savages they don't know any better but
it's like hold on
i don't remember once in my life being
in the united states where somebody
looked at me and said hey
i want to know more about you please
come over and have sure
i have never had that experience here
hospitality
is their game dude they're so good at it
yeah they're so good at it you're like
yeah just come over
yeah go ahead but you know what's weird
though here's what's weird uh it's their
etiquette to
give you as much make sure your teacup
is full make sure your
cup is to the brim every time you take
make sure it's full wow
but it is totally against our culture
for guests to use the whole bathroom
really so i would go to these dinners
and i have to hold my pee
so hard because it's like it's
so bad to use there
that'd be so funny if that's just not
even true they're just [ __ ] with you
i'm just
but that wasn't that every house i went
to please drink more but you can't use
our bathroom so like
they put every effort into making sure
my teacup was full and they're like why
aren't you drinking
tea you don't like teeth i like tea i
just have to pee really bad then when
i'm like uh look
i have to use the bathroom then they
look at me like
yeah it's like this is the weirdest
culture
that's like so interesting ever wow
and at the same time i was meeting
people out there that it was just
like two months you meet a lot of people
but
one of the people that stood out like
there there's actually a christian
village i was in this city called
urbil which is technically kurdistan
it's all kurds not arabic
you know and um we were visiting this
christian church because we're in a
christian village and surrounding it is
this giant
giant temple like i've never seen before
and it's called the temple of jonah
because urbil like um
and like mosul that area
is actually nineveh ancient
yeah that's where jonah went so there's
this
massive temple dedicated towards for
jonah into god the theist not a muslim
temple
not exactly jewish not even christian
but it's honoring
aka god allah or whatever and
i'm hanging out there and i'm looking
for some diet coke because i'm craving
it
and the wild thing is in the christian
village they can you can sell alcohol
there because christians can drink
yeah so the muslim guys come in and buy
alcohol and they
try um
so i'm hanging out there and i'm
chatting um
with uh some of the guys i went with in
the same program
and then i hear this voice like hey you
guys speak english
like turn around like what the yeah
but it's a kurdish guy you know and like
well
whoa you speak english too right he
starts dropping n bombs and
no stuff actually so his english was was
pretty good because he was a special
iraqi special forces he told us yeah
and he works with the marines and
american special forces too
because he can combat and translate
and and he was like what are you guys
doing here
just hanging out right he goes you guys
want a beer you guys want to hang out
he's like beer we're gonna get a beer
he goes follow me i'll show you and
it smells sketchy look there's there's
not a whole lot of street lights in iraq
yeah it's already dark and i can't see
anything but
at the time in the mindset i was in i'm
already in iraq
so what's the worst what's the word i
just kept saying yes and yes to
everything while
you're there so i said yep let's go oh
my god
so we're going through these pitch black
alleys
in like the middle of her belt and i
don't even know where i am
i don't know where i'm going i'm just
following him anyway
and then we get to this door and then
they speak
speak some kurdish and then i go
upstairs
and it's a bar and everyone in there is
chinese
what the what i'm like what what's going
and i was like
no did you i was like hey i'm not
chinese like oh that's why i brought you
i thought you
you could you you know them or something
that's [ __ ] funny dude
i'm like wait there's a chinese bar in
the middle of iraq
like welcome yeah yo chinese
entrepreneurship is like no no
it's like you know where we could open
up a bar yeah
i don't care dude it was a while it was
one of the wildest experiences of my
life i'm sitting here in a chinese bar
in the middle of iraq with this
iraqi special forces dude that's why i'm
chopping it up having beers with him
you know and that's the thing though he
just wanted to talk to somebody
you know anybody yeah because
in his culture he can't talk about
things he does
you know or knows or whatever and he
doesn't know me he starts unloading
he starts telling me some crazy [ __ ]
like what like um
just how many people he kills oh my god
like that and
because he's with the us military about
how they really mow
[ __ ] down and
he told me like there was some espionage
in the barracks
oh yeah and some files
they found were copied just they found
out something was copied
you know and
you know how a lot of southeast asian
women go to the middle east to
to like do like made work or like
butlers or whatever yeah they found out
it was
like some filipino girl working
espionage
and then he told me that
they [ __ ] her and killed her
oh it's like he said like 50 guys
he was talking he was saying this like
so nonchalantly
and i'm like it's just sipping on my
beer like
wait this is like the iraqi military
yeah
this dude you know uh because they found
that she was a spy
yeah she was a spy they didn't like put
it through some
no they they they threw away
you know and he was telling me a lot of
[ __ ] up stories like this
and you know uh
pretty much as the christian missionary
i am or whatever
he was telling me like he sees
all the people he kills every night
every time he goes it closes his eyes he
sees everyone he's killed
and that's why he's an alcoholic this is
why he drinks every night he black he
goes he haunts him he haunts him
he blacks out every night so you know
that's why he drinks and
so he has this tattoo it says christina
on his arm
i'm like why is it say christine on your
arm so he's my girlfriend
from ohio i'm like what
he's like yeah she was this marine girl
and she was stationed in iraq
and they hooked up and they're in love i
guess and then she went back home
and then he said there's he's like
there's a lot of mexicans in the marines
so they can get their citizenship
and they all do tattoos they do it
really good he started showing me all
his tattoos
he's like i always find girls yeah no he
just goes to mexicans i can do tattoo
and like should try to get it done
because he's he's iraqi he's not
supposed to have tattoos
so but also he's kurdish kurdish
not all ethnically kurdish people aren't
muslim
right they're called the sons of david
when the jews were in exile
you know out of uh israel and they were
taken to babylon
you know the like those are them the
people who were left over over the years
so they still considered
some themselves the sons of david yeah
[ __ ] wild
yeah so which is why god sent jonah to
nineveh it's like my people are still
there
you know yeah anyway like
there's a whole lot of reasons why like
theologically why it went there too and
how much
what it means to me um this guy's a nut
bag
yeah and it got to a point where i was
just like
so uh you know like
do you just you just keep drinking and
drinking or whatever like
like he's just like well how do you what
do you do you're a christian right
you know he's like do you have a bible
i'm like yeah
he goes i've never seen a bible in my
life and when he was holding it he was
just like
you can have it he goes really me i i
can't
i'm too evil i've done too many bad
things this is the way they think about
religion
you know like especially of the
unworthiness this is why
like we grow up as christians because we
know we ain't [ __ ] sometimes
yeah yeah you know and and this is where
i started doing the
events it's like i i know you did some
[ __ ] but this is your personal
thing like you keep this bible and
it's like thank you thank you i'm gonna
keep this and he got up and left
i said where are you going he's like
exactly i'm in this now bar i'm like
what the [ __ ]
hey hey wait wait wait wait now i'm
strange
oh my god dude in the middle of iraq
thank you dark allies in this chinese
bar like hey i don't know these people
yeah he's like you can go back to your
family now it's like these are my family
dude
but you know but here's the thing about
iraq
i go out into the street and i look for
a main street and cars are passing by
all i gotta do is wave my hand somebody
stops and i'm like hey can you take me
towards uh
the or bill the bazaar this or whatever
i name i know where i'm going
from there they'll pick me up and go
anybody
wow anybody what is that about in that
culture they just
it's about helping people yeah and you
know what you it's not like a fair but
people just you know get your fiverr or
whatever give money you know and most
time when i give money like no
like i just you know they just wanted to
pick me up
yeah everybody the the thing is like
they want to experience too they like
experience and
doing new things they're not like
backwards as crazy people not only that
they [ __ ] hate terrorists too okay
yeah
they hate terrorists the most of the
time that out
i was there i was hanging out with this
guy who was a translator as well for the
marines
in one week his sister
was killed in a black ied a terrorist
attack
the following week his fiancee was
killed
[ __ ] an attack so he said he started
studying english
so he can go be a translator so he can
watch them kill
terrorists so he can kill terrorists
legally wow these
people hate terrorists too yeah they're
not
like if you're a [ __ ] goddamn
[ __ ] idiot
if you want to call all of them
terrorists you're a [ __ ] idiot i
swear to god
well that's this is the hard part and i
uh man i was just talking about this
with my buddy tony who uh he
we were talking about how there was like
certain korean kids in our college that
hated japanese people like his third
fourth generation japanese kids right
and you know you know what that feels
like because you were like that too you
know until you went to japan
yeah and the hard thing is like
sometimes i would have commerce and they
would ask me like well
they're your people too you were born in
korea i was like listen these are
third fourth generation japanese kids
they don't know what's going on and on
top of that to go even deeper than that
there are people in japan who didn't
know what was going on this is
imperial japan this is what the
leadership was doing they weren't
sitting there rooting for the death of
these people
they were literally living their life
and they didn't know what was going on
they didn't vote for annexation yeah
they didn't
vote to like colonize korea they didn't
do that [ __ ] yeah and you know
culturally speaking for them
they have they they do their job they
live their lives and they don't question
a lot of things
so they're just going about it wasn't
like they were sitting i think because
they're they're comparing japanese
culture to american culture right where
we see something go back and
american people are rising up like you
can't do that type of [ __ ] it's not like
that in japan
yeah they trust the government they
trust the system and they just go about
their lives and they
they do what they do best there's a
harmony in order so
japanese religion now is
harmony it's being japanese you
do what you're supposed to do and you do
it really well
you have a social job too you know to
fulfill
right and that's what's something i
definitely appreciate about their
culture as well
but i came back you know after two weeks
in iraq not two weeks two months
and there's a definite like
this world doesn't make any sense still
kind of thing
you know because i still find it funny
that guy just left you at that bar
he just takes your bible he goes this is
what i need enjoy your night
hey wyom is the same thing you're like
hey you did your thing
you know had you have you know in iraq
all right go back home now
and now like your entire world has
changed
and whatever um but i started clashing a
lot with my church from there
because at this point like i i did
i sold my [ __ ] i left my job i
followed jesus to the ends of the earth
you know source you went to the source
yeah
you were in babylon man but i was
taking it like wait why am i doing all
this
why isn't anyone else doing this no
because when you read it i'm reading i
don't know if you're reading the same
bible as me but he's telling us to sell
everything
he's telling us to leave our jobs and
i can tell looking back i was getting
pretty annoying
where i was the bible thumper
fundamentalist where i
were i was constantly challenging people
when they didn't need to be
you know so i know my role yeah and
coming back in the way i handled things
where eventually it led me to leave
church
you know what the interesting thing is
though like i have a very weird
relationship with that because
a part of me is like you know the bible
thumper that kind of
gets on you about specific [ __ ] a part
of me hates them but a part of me
respects them
and the reason why is because they're
about their [ __ ] yeah you know
uh like for me too i have i say i have
somewhat of a lackadaisical faith in
christianity right meaning that i am
probably the christian that kind of
does things in a way that uh molds to my
life rather than me molding my life
to to what christ wants right and that's
this is a struggle that anybody with
religion will always have
but the great thing about quote-unquote
bible thumpers though i do believe that
they should soften up a little bit
at least they're about their [ __ ] right
that's that's why i see people who
believe in the muslim religion right i
see these people they wake up
they fast they pray to god every time
every morning
before the sun rise this when i see that
type of dedication at least you're not
bullshitting anybody and you're not
bullshitting yourself
you know what you're about you know and
i think
that's the struggle that a lot of people
have when it comes to any type of faith
or religion
it's the part of letting go of yourself
for this greater cause
the that's what people feel freedom in
right
but sometimes for us it's like damn it's
hard for me i'm like
i could say i'm christian as much as i
want right but when if i'm a
definitively like biblically speaking am
i the best christian
absolute [ __ ] lutely not you know but
at the same time i'm gonna say
theologically yeah
no you're fine you're good the the idea
of
good and bad christian um
doesn't make sense to me you just are
because
theologically nothing can separate you
from no matter what you do
yeah the most [ __ ] up things you could
say or do or anything
which is why i gave the absolute worst
example of this murdering rapist
david you are not a murdering rapist
okay yeah right
theologically uh god can do what he
wants with that guy
you know and for you same deal
um i think people get caught up because
they can't tell the difference
between piety and holiness
you know piety is self-righteousness
where you and your works gives you
a reputation as to why you need to be
listened to
yeah where holiness is
holiness is attributed to godliness
right what does that mean it just means
set apart right yeah like michael jordan
is holy
why because he's set apart amongst all
the alphas and the tops are the best
he's above the alphas he's above the
best
yeah that's called that's holy you know
because you set yourself apart from that
and i feel like i was trying my best to
be
holy and people how they accepted
or interpreted it maybe it's me too was
piety
and i became a social outcast i think
where i got taken out of being a youth
leader i got taken out of being a praise
team leader i got taken out of college
ministry
and i was just a congregation member now
you know like forcibly or you made that
choice
it was more or less the leadership
making these decisions
and i'm like because they felt like what
do they feel like you were
what i clashed with them a lot because
of this this theology got you
because i'd constantly challenge them
because they're the pastors
at least i can talk to them about the
bible and just be like yo why are you
saying this in your sermon when the
bible says that
yeah i was that guy too but at the same
time like
i you know if you want to talk about
bible [ __ ] like you're not
i'm not going to talk about it with my
friends they don't want to talk about
that
well that's that's that's problem in
leadership as well because they're
looking for
absolute authority versus versus
challenging themselves right
so when you have somebody and this is
this this can go all the way back to
just parenting styles too
right because there'll be a time too
when your kids will challenge you and
ask you about questions
and uh i have to be if i am if i become
a father i have to be well equipped to
actually have these conversations with
them
um and what happens to like a lot of
leadership specifically i'm not sure if
this is like in all churches right but
i'd see a lot of korean people like that
in these leadership positions where
somebody would ask questions and they'd
look at that as defiance
yes rather than curiosity yeah rather
than having an open discussion because
religion should be discussed
and when you know when i was a youth
leader too one of the things that i
always told the kids to do
they go well what if this happens i was
like listen you're going to be
challenged in your faith 24 7.
if you want to be christian you're about
it you got to go ahead and face these
challenges head to head
because you'll be these these thoughts
don't go away you'll either
push it down and then something's going
to come up where you're faced with that
question again
and then you'll try to push it down
again and it actually makes your faith
weaker
because you're not because if you take
that challenge and then you start to
understand the concept better it
actually strengthens your faith
not just with religion anything else
right right when we talk about politics
when we talk about
french we talk about personal
relationships you you choose to ignore
these things especially in a leadership
role
you start to [ __ ] yourselves up and you
actually [ __ ] up that relationship with
the person that you have
when you own a business employees will
question your methodology
right when i had that softer spot one of
the things that i always told them was
like look
you work at the store more than i do
right
if you see something wrong with the
system that we have implemented
speak up i may shoot you down i may
disagree with you
but i need to know that you're thinking
something because i might not be able to
see it
you're not questioning my authority
you're actually
causing me to think about solutions and
problems right you know
so it came to a point where
you know when you're like 13 uh in
presbyterian churches uh you get
confirmed
right if you weren't baptized when you
were uh
whatever right and but you have to take
a a class
on the gospel and you gotta know if like
a theological sense if whether you're
saved or not
and one year the
entire class failed because of this new
pastor
you know and he has he has an
armenian-based
theology when presbyterian is very
calvinist
you don't need to know what they mean
there's two separate
and that's the kind of stuff i kept
challenging these pastors with
so here's the thing i'm gonna i'm gonna
drop this story now
because i told them
if they don't go and apologize and
repent for what they did
that i was gonna tell this story
publicly yeah and i've given them their
chance it's been a year
even i'm shaking because it's some real
[ __ ] yeah
um i'm not doing anything at church
anymore i'm just some congregation kid
now
yeah and
do you know what the drama is drama
is a really really big organization like
a big conference
um i think it's our oc jesus awakening
movement for america
all right and they do these huge huge
conferences where like
thousands of korean christians show up
yeah but then they'll have like david
crowder band and like john piper's
all the homeless known like yeah
when i first saw dave ricardo as a side
note when i first saw david crowder come
on stage i never knew what he looked
like
they had a david crowder it was at like
a six flags and they had a david crowder
concert there
came through and i was like who the [ __ ]
is that homeless guy over there get him
off the
david that's david crowder i'm like
that's not david crowder that guy is a
crackhead
i was like yo this is nice
but um yeah i like i've been to those
jama conferences before they go in every
city across america
where there's koreans yeah um so la
philly new york virginia i guess atlanta
um chicago but finally for the first
time ever they were coming to washington
and uh so
they were going to have a huge gentleman
conference in washington but now they're
going to have it in tacoma
you know not seattle or anything tacoma
you know the the second city of the
state and
i guess all the church leaders around
the puget sound
got together and they met with the drama
leaders like uh we need help sending
this up getting the sound the band
the all the logistics and then they were
like uh
we need someone to do a video like a
commercial who's gonna do it
and all the pastors apparently in the
meeting were like ed
edge do it you know that's the context i
got because that's
so these three pastors english ministry
pastors at my church
came to me they're like ed jama wants
you to do this video for them
yeah you know and i'm like cool i'll do
it for a thousand bucks
yeah they're like what wait why can't
you do it for free
i'm like why would i do it for free yeah
and i'm like and they're like uh okay so
like but the next subsequent day like
days and weeks they'd be like
ed um why can't you do this why can't
you do this video
and i'm like well if i make the video i
wanna make
it's gonna take a week and that's gonna
cost about a thousand bucks
and that's pretty fair and then
they started like scolding me and like
for what
rebuking me like because i won't do it
for free
why won't you do this for the kingdom or
hold on a second why can't you do this
for god
you know people have to make a [ __ ]
living right right i'm like
you go speak at other churches every now
and then they pay you
they pay you the hypocrisy and that is
so [ __ ] unreal
like that makes my blood boil dude like
i i know what you when you when you
when you mention this stuff i mean not
to cut you off but it's like
i hate it when people use god and a
religion to get favoritism out of other
people to get what they want what they
want
it's not that it's not necessary it's
not that they don't have the means to do
it right they go well
you want to get in good with god right i
was like well i didn't know god was
[ __ ] like santa claus yeah i didn't
know i had to check off my nice list to
have this better relationship with god
you know like what are you talking about
like dude i believe god told me to go to
iraq
you know to a terrible place what i
thought was a terrible place at least
yeah you know it's like i think you're
trying to get something out of me
you know it's like i don't think god
always wants you to do you know get the
stuff you want sometimes he wants you to
do things you're scared to do yeah you
know and you know
this is what happened too i bet you
they're just like well it's like if you
even if you said this reason if you said
to him like well
i have bills to pay so god will provide
he's like
no kid it's like you know you know god
will provide that for you if you do this
for him
no talk about some cultish language so
that's not how it works guy
yeah and about the weeks leading up to
this big event
they kept coming up to me they're like
and
at one point even one of them was like
he was playing basketball
and he stopped playing one of the
pastors and he put the ball aside he
goes
come here you know what took me to this
empty room and he started just
putting it down on me but first of all
the fact that he thinks that he could
talk to you like that
is deplorable you know just
first of all that's anti-christ-like as
[ __ ] by the way i'm like
24 or 25 years old
i'm not some [ __ ] kid yeah you know i
like to consider myself a professional
in video at that point too yeah
and he's just like don't you know that
god would bless you if do this for free
and i can't tell you every single almost
like
nine out of every 10 pastors i've met
have tried to get me to do a video for
them and they've used that line
like they're all some kind of [ __ ]
prophet
look i i haven't seen any in one of
those [ __ ] blessings i'll just say
that right
yeah but that's just not how it works
like
they know this but the fact that they
could think that they could use that as
some type of leverage like
hey you know i'm the key to heaven right
you know that right so if you do me a
favor
yo i can guarantee you're getting into
heaven it's essentially what they're
saying
which is literally the most ridiculous
and disgusting abuse of power
yeah that these type of leaders use
right it's like
and they're doing that because they're
gonna take this piece of information
like hey ed didn't do this video work i
did because i got ed to do this and he's
going to show
their higher ups like hey did you see
this awesome video that happened
yeah i got it because i had to do it for
free because they're going to go to
their next church that they think you
get hired at and they're going to have
to put that on their resume
right it's just the dumbest thing on
earth that's just so deplorable dude
but it doesn't end there because
i end up i ended up uh
going to drama you know just to show up
you know the experience i see my friends
they're the worship team and they're
they're doing it three nights in a row i
see my friend he
his whole company they provided the
sound system cost tens of thousands of
dollars you know i see speakers who flew
in from virginia new york
a friend of mine from hawaii who they
flew in to speak
you know and then on
i just was just like even feeling it
myself i was like all these people got
paid
this thing cost tens of thousands of
dollars to put together but i wasn't
worth a thousand bucks
yeah and right there at
this event i was like peace i'm out of
here
i'm going i'm leaving church and i found
that pastor
and i sat him down and i was like you
and i
have never had a bible study together
i've never heard
your sermons you've never prayed for me
never had a meal i've never been to your
house you've never been in my house
and you tell me that i have a pride
problem
you know why not yeah you don't know me
you don't [ __ ] know me
and i was like i'm i i'm leaving i told
him
i'm out of here i'm leaving this church
my family grew up in this church for
[ __ ] 30 40 years i'm leaving this
church
and i left you know and
after that like world started opening up
um there's a huge church in seattle
called mars hill church
they hit me up and came and wanted to
talk to me and they wanted to pay me
50k a year to show up on the weekends
and do a video for them
because that's what you're worth yeah
and i was like what
i couldn't comprehend what you want to
what
it's like yeah that you're a
professional and it blew my mind because
i always
was treated like [ __ ] by the korean
churches and korean ministries i'm like
thousand dollars yeah that's all i asked
for
you know to cover the cost because the
cost of a week's worth of worth and
which
by the way i wasn't sleeping if i was
doing that kind of work
by the way they got some guy in la to do
the video the theme of the event was
called i heart tacoma
the video was like space needle seattle
yeah seattle skyline
[ __ ] so like you know it was just
this is all horse [ __ ] to me now like
you guys still want to play your games
like that so that
you can get ahead in life in some which
way or
i don't know yeah peace i bounced and i
actually even turned down
that 50k job because that's not what i
was looking for either
in my life at that time i was definitely
looking for mentorship and discipleship
which they were offering but if it comes
at a price it does it like
it comes with a lot of weight yeah
and this other pastor in seattle i just
i went to check it out and i sat down
with him
and i told him about why i left my
church in tacoma
and then he goes ed
you need to know this because it's your
business
right you need to know because this is
about you i hope i'm not here like just
i'm not here just gossiping about these
people this is what happened
and he says i was at those meetings we
all said ed ed loves jesus and he needs
to do these videos
you know he'll do it all these pastors
from other churches
were hyping my name yeah and so that
they went to my pastors at my church and
were like can you please
ask ed to the video we have a thousand
dollars to pay him
so but when they came to me they said
there's no money can you do it for free
and i said i want a thousand dollars
and they were like like no it
no you know why can't you do it for free
but they were [ __ ] pocketing it
i so this is where it goes for weeks
they kept fighting with me to do the
video
you know not only that then they lowered
it to eight hundred dollars
oh my god they said okay john was
willing to give you 800
to do this video this is this is like
the worst thing ever this is why i was
shaking
before i told this story so
how do they lie to you i don't [ __ ]
know and i can't figure it out and it's
been ruining my life
and my faith for the last decade it's
it's which is why i'm not a christian
anymore to this day because of this [ __ ]
you know because i have no answers and i
don't understand why because last year i
called
called them out i told them to go tell
the pastor what they did
yeah so what would they say when you
asked them they're like no
i don't know it's up to them yeah but
but i heard he told me like there was a
thousand dollars for you this pastor
he's like
we had a thousand dollars set aside for
you yeah
and they kept coming back saying you
didn't want to do it that you were
too good for that you were that you were
and then he was like that
doesn't sound like ed yeah you know
and so he was at jama
and then he confronted those pastors
like where's ed why isn't he yeah doing
the video and then he they said again
ah edward i get paid
right and then he said look around
the sound system these speakers from
hawaii and new york and virginia
tens of thousands of dollars yes the the
band
you pay for every session they're
playing three times a day jeez
you know it's just not cheap by the way
yeah and so it's just like
why what you do a car wash money yeah
and so he opens his phone in front of
my passers and he calls these two other
guys
and then and they're in they're in
seattle yeah it's like an
hour drive down at tacoma they're like
hey can you come down to tacoma and
record some video for jama and they
weren't planning to come
and on the phone on speaker he they said
yes pastor we'll be there right away
right and so my pastor was like whoa how
do you get your congregation to do that
and he's like oh i love
i love my congregation he said don't you
love edward
wow yeah and he's telling me the story
and i
felt so vindicated yeah that somebody
was out there standing up for me
yeah he called them out for that [ __ ]
you know
and then but the thing was like i was on
the same page
at least i got to say my word but i left
because of that
it's just a thousand bucks but the
principle behind all that was just like
they don't give a [ __ ]
about me of course i'm not worth it for
them
i mean to put it simply is just they
thought that you were somebody
that they could take advantage of and
they couldn't do it so it frustrated
them
but like this guy he should he should be
grateful
that we even asked him to do this stuff
so they didn't value as a person
and so when you said no they're like who
is this guy to say no to us
and for them it was a guy like we just
mentioned it on this podcast it's a
pride and ego thing
and they thought that they could take
advantage of because they couldn't it
hurt their pride in their ego
but like what were they gonna do with a
thousand bucks i needed that money
i know well that's what i'm saying like
that's why i always tell people like if
you're gonna do free work
right free work makes sense i've done
free work before and i've learned a lot
from it if it's from a learning
perspective right
you can gain something from it he's
already established
he already knew his value people already
knew his value
and even then you lowered your value to
help out the church for just a thousand
dollars just to cover expenses
that's all that you were asking for and
even then it wasn't worth it like i
don't want
like i know people who have done
internship and free work and they've
taken a lot of stuff from me
right like obviously they got paid
eventually
but they got a regular job but they
learned a lot on the spot and they
they've
they've gained something from it but
when you're coming from a position
you're not offering anything
what what do you do like this is not an
internship position this is a job that
you're asking for
it's like the kingdom what am i going to
get
i would die [ __ ] yes
to yeah what do i need to gain more yeah
i had to seek
god more by doing free labor what was
that in the bible
yeah what the hell like and this is
where it kind of [ __ ] with me too
where i was just like come on you don't
think i'm this stupid do you what was
the church that
which church was this it's my home
church and these three pastors aren't
from tacoma
yeah they're from wherever else and they
got hired into the youth
the college in english and and
children's ministry so there were three
english ministry pastors how old are
they
varied between 30 to 40.
and yeah and this is just like i know
they know better
but this was clearly some weird [ __ ]
plan and was it worth it for a thousand
dollars
no that was a power trip when i left
church is when my career started taking
off
yeah which breaks my heart too because
of
all the things that i love to do for the
church and
the great things like when creative
ideas and even innovation
technologically with videos
that i wanted to do and it was just like
uh
i just felt like a [ __ ] stain you know
and
maybe that's part of the calvinist idea
the word is just like you're not good
enough
you're not supposed to be good enough
stop putting yourself up on a pedestal
down down down your your your pride your
pride your pride just stifling me
the the concept i hated this [ __ ] too
when they would talk about
you know we talked about pride and eagle
like i mentioned before but i like it
when people i hate it when people
shove it in your face only when they
wanted something from you
right so you're doing something that you
feel like is worth your time or you're
doing and then go hold on you're being
prideful it's like but hold on a second
no i'm not
you know so it's like i i always you
always had to like subjugate
subjugate yourself to somebody else's
will because it was quote unquote what
they said was for christ
but it was really for them for
themselves you know and
i hate it when people would use religion
or they would use jesus christ
as a tool to get what they wanted out of
people which is the most
evil [ __ ] that you could ever do and all
i could think about too when i was
younger was like you're going to get
yours eventually i know you are
right and so for me like for example
when i told you that guy who um
who slapped me upside my head you know
in front of church in front of people
and i'd take him aside and i was like
i'ma [ __ ] cut you open
like it's not very christ-like for me to
say that but i was a very angry kid
you know and he never did it again but
that guy lo and behold
uh when i started popping off on youtube
guy hits me up
right he goes hey man i'm not sure if
you remember me like i went to your
church blah blah i was like one of the
older kings whatever what not i'm like
[ __ ] i know exactly
who you are he's like yeah you mean like
[ __ ] yeah and he's like well you know i
do stuff with youth now
and i wanted to know if you wanted to
come in and talk about your personal
experiences i remember i wrote back to
him i was like well you should talk
about that personal experience where you
slap me upside my head
and then you basically try to make me a
[ __ ] in front of everybody because you
thought it was cool
it's like if you have problems with kids
bullying people you should help out your
personal experience how you used to try
to bully people
right right and then he was like he just
wrote back he goes hey
i'm sorry but like i you know i'm sorry
if i came out of you nowhere like asking
for a favor i was like yeah you did come
out no no
ask me for a favor but i was like have
you told that story where you
you used to be that guy he goes no i
haven't i was like we'll start there and
then hit me up after
right right so don't don't try to hide
behind your fake piety
acting like you're mr perfect if you
haven't told your personal story where
you were trying to bully people at
church to do your bidding
and you want me to come in as a guest
speaker talk about your story first
humble yourself and then i'll come
through right you know which is why we
don't have a problem telling these
stories
because we know who we are yeah we're
deadly honest about it yeah so even like
in the last church i was at i have no
problem confessing my sin
yeah christians have a problem listening
to confessions
yeah i'm like yo guys like
you know i did a whole lot of cocaine
this past weekend
and i got i just got passed out drunk
and i think
you know whatever like these guys would
be frozen with their eyes wide open like
they didn't know the first thing to do
so even like when i'm
saying yo all this racist [ __ ] is
happening me at my store
i could use your help like uh nobody
showed up
yeah you know except for you know i'm
gonna give it to um
the pastors at that church and um my
friends
you know david and june and uh
josh they came through for me but like
out of a church of like
250 people you know what i will say
though like
there's a big reason why i stopped going
to korean churches and
this was what it was like right i felt a
lot of people would fake the funk
you know right like on the outside on
the exterior they're very good about
talking about christ
only because they would reflect how good
they are as a person when i started
going to
more i wouldn't say america i would say
americanized church but people
just just non-korean churches i found
out that these people were so much more
about that life
non-confucius that's what it is like
i wouldn't even ask they would i would
get these texts like hey how are you
doing i'm like right
what like nobody would ever ask how i
was doing right you know
they would ask like hey would you want
to come out to these bible studies i
never was asked that
it was either i kind of brought myself
in
you know or then i became a part of the
group yes
these people would reach out or even
something this small right
i remember when i first went to an
americanized church right it was it was
a black church right
uh it was a church called bayside of
south sacramento which i love
uh our head pastor passed away uh pastor
sherwood
um but this was such a new experience
i walked i walked in before i walk in
there's a greeter at the door
korean churches never had a greeter for
me the ones i grew up in yeah right
they're like good morning how are you
what's your name and i stood there i was
like
what you know i thought i was going to
walk in and sit down and
do whatever and they're like hey are you
new here he was like well here's the
panel if you have any questions let me
know
afterwards we have we have drinks and
whatever what not in snacks just stay
around and
you know have a good time and i was just
stunned
because i never felt that type of just
stranger warmth you know this person
doesn't know who i am they asked me how
i was doing
very odd we go sit down and the first
thing we do and i see a lot of like
korean churches now implement this and i
think they got it from white people
churches
was hey look at you look to your
neighbor and say good morning and say
hello
and that [ __ ] was awkward for me i never
had to do that
so they were i looked to the side and i
was like good morning they're like good
morning how are you and they shook my
head and i'm like
these people are [ __ ] nice they want
me here they're so sweet yeah you know
and it was just such a pleasant feeling
to be welcomed by people who i didn't
know
and they seemed like they were more
about that life than i've ever felt in
my life you know
it i think there's just one of those
things where because i live so far away
from every church i've ever gone to was
just like i just want to be
part of this and accept it now i'm gonna
hold up my end and say i was
a really annoying kid yeah even my
when i went to that past i was like yo
why why is it like this for me why are
people talking about my head and he goes
edward some people think you're annoying
yo it's the worst when a korean
no well i mean it's so the whole idea
behind it is just like
the the core faith of christianity is
that you're not enough
yeah and only through jesus are you
enough so we have this
singer from korea come in and we're a
korean american church but
in her i think she thought she was
coming to an america she's coming to
america
yeah she's kind of singing for americans
but it's a korean church yeah
so she had this english like a lion set
up
you know everybody we thought that jesus
christ
i ain't nothing but a piece of cat
veggie
oh that's my favorite line dude i used
that life so much because of how
[ __ ] funny it is dude i am nothing
but a carpet
but at the same time though i that was
one of my mantras just like i'm not
enough i'm not good
yeah that's christianity though right i
need jesus i need jesus because i'm not
good
i think some part of us like if you want
to talk about sin
fine right but then who you are inherit
at least what i believe in now
because of how toxic the idea of me
[ __ ] on myself so hard is
is where where i give myself some
intrinsic value now
yeah you know some born humanity
writes where i'm i'm saying that's so
interesting because i feel like that
concept right there was developed in the
korean church because when i went to the
americanized church
it was never that you're not enough it's
like god believes that you are enough
you know and he loves you and he cares
about you which
even that concept was like mind-blowing
to me right you know
if god thinks you are enough you know
you're you're an imperfect human being
but that's good
you know try your best every day right
because to us it's just like
c you know okay b plus like you know
and you're an idiot anything dude dude
there's a if you grew up in a korean
church
and you [ __ ] up every korean parent
would tell you this [ __ ] that you would
do something bad they go
yeah that's satan that's satan
you know you know what i mean oh you
want to go to hell
yeah i was like do you want to go to
hell it was everything was through
fear-mongering you know i wouldn't do
things because
i was so scared to go to hell right i
remember when i when i first jacked off
i was like [ __ ] i'm going to hell but
you know what baby boy about to take
this risk
you know at least you don't i think at
least
if they took a different approach to
that [ __ ]
with the youth and just be honest about
it's like we know you jackoff
you know all your kids jack all you
unless you have the gift of celibacy
yeah i don't know how you're all jacking
up you know and deal with it from there
stop stop trying to stop them you're
checking off
it's as human as a human you have to
deal with that [ __ ] and look well how
well i don't know sorry that's why i'm
not in the church anymore yeah it's it's
hard man like dealing with your
with your religion and your religious
thoughts and you know for anybody who
out there who
wants to be christian or you know feels
like there's a drive for you to follow
christ then
i'll tell you this is like uh [ __ ]
picking out churches like picking out
friends like you gotta find one that
faces finding a club
yeah it's hard it's there's just no
doubt you're finding a club
yeah there's a church that yeah i
remember that i mentioned the church
that i went to and this one person was
like yeah you go to that church no
wonder you're not really a christian i'm
like
all right bro i was like just to let you
know judging me you going to hell first
[ __ ]
and i was i was like that yeah when i
got back from my i was like
the word yeah [ __ ] joel scene
joel olsen is a very unique human being
yeah used to prosperity it's the
prosperity gospel
and that's trash straight up all the way
around yeah straight up you know
i believe in god and jesus christ all
that stuff [ __ ] joel osteen though
this [ __ ] and his concept of
like prosperity gospel is is the most
ridiculous [ __ ] on earth man
going to hell with me i'll see you there
[ __ ]
like this concept that he's like you
know what my wife needs like a new house
uh
i need i need about 50 bedrooms yeah
with a hundred bathrooms
i always had you know i talked about my
cousin's a pastor right yeah
and he his his gripe that he i remember
i mentioned to him i asked him
i was asking him about what do you think
about uh these mega churches with
superstar pastors he's like i don't know
you know what he was telling me is like
i don't know how they do that
because there are people in this
congregation that are barely making ends
meet and they're tightening ten percent
of their income
and they're walking around with their
escalades their bodyguards their their
10 million dollar homes yeah and in
their con in their mind they're like
well i'm helping
god's you know sheep i'm helping guide
them so this is what i deserve this is
what god's given me
but he's like you have people who are
barely able to pay their bills
and you're living in excess how do you
look at your congregation
and say i'm a believer of christ and god
will present you with all these
opportunities when they're
they're literally funding your lifestyle
that was the question i asked myself
when i was really questioning all of
this was
like if jesus was alive today you know
in in america and he needed a car
yeah right to get to point a to point b
and he had a 30 000 budget what kind of
car would you buy
right and some people will say mercedes
you know some people might say or
whatever honda or whatever
and some people for me it is my belief
that if with all the information we have
out there knowing that people are
starving and dying
you know i think jesus would spend maybe
two g's on a car and
give the rest away yeah that sounds like
jesus to me
yeah and i was like none of us do that
though none of us actually think that
way none of us want to do that
yeah which was where i was like okay
then let me sell my [ __ ] let me really
[ __ ] do this
and coming out of it though other
christians look at you you did a good
thing you didn't nice
i can't do it but good for you it's good
for you but i'm like wait so then are
you
christian am i like what i
i was just so lost because all these
people are fine
just living their regular lives making
100k
you know while they're suffering and
where i was digging in the world where i
was like i need to you need to go help
suffering
and i couldn't balance the fact of
living in a suburban
town with a nice church in the middle of
a [ __ ] ghetto actually
you know yeah and i don't know it's just
so hard to call myself a christian
there's just a lot of those internal
battles with everything that you do
whether it's religion or
you know as you get older it's like a
lot of the ideals that you grew up with
that you thought were complete truths
that were just
infallible truths yeah and you'll start
questioning these things throughout your
whole life yeah
and i've you know i've definitely felt
that way too you know i just
learned to have it just trust myself and
just i don't want to say [ __ ] them but
it's more you know that is what i'm
saying yeah
you know what i mean like you're walking
around you know you got a lambo you got
all this other [ __ ] and you know that
people are starving
and struggling within your congregation
and you could walk around and
be fine with that [ __ ] you bro like [ __ ]
you and i say that not from a place of
you know i am judging you why because my
dad uh started up a couple of churches
in sacramento he ran his own business
put himself through like seminary school
he has a masters in theology
and he never took a cent from his church
right and we were struggling
he didn't take a [ __ ] dime from those
churches he didn't get paid for his [ __ ]
he took his time and his money and he
built those churches up and he didn't
take a [ __ ] sense so don't tell me it
can't be done
do not tell me it can't be done we were
never rich we were
lower lower middle class right which we
worked to get to that yeah
and i was around a man who sacrificed
everything didn't take a cent from his
church and did it out of
his belief in christ and the good will
of his own heart my dad was a lot of
things he was jack as an [ __ ]
but definitely what you can say was my
dad was an honest person and
when when he was about his face he was
really about his faith so when i see
people and they're talking about well
god wants me so what does i say about my
father
you know is my father this this this
this uh he he just has it wrong
you know he he raised two kids perfectly
healthy yeah we struggled here and there
but he did such a good job as a parent i
didn't feel like i was struggling
yeah you know so how can you say it
can't be done
or how can you say that it's it doesn't
make sense when it has made sense from
from an ex from a very close example in
my life
so it's hard for me to kind of subscribe
to their thought of god will
wants me to prosper this hard right i
just can't i can't do it yeah it's hard
for a lot of people on the outside
looking at a church
on the inside and see a a mercedes bmw
rules
or whatever meanwhile so like my church
being tacoma tacoma
isn't you know known for being you know
such a luxurious city you know there was
across the street from my house i
remember in uh seventh grade we had a
field trip bible study field trip but we
were gonna go watch a movie
yeah and so they load us up in the van
and we're going out the gate
and cop car stopped us skirt right
and they're just staying there staying
there right more cop cars then this
swat team goes in they bust down the
door
we're watching this from our church fan
across the street yeah
and they pull out these dudes and
they're handcuffed and zip tied and they
load them
in the paddy wagon and then these dudes
and hazmat suits going
and they're just going like it looks
like outbreak or something and there's
like there's a giant meth house inside
you know it's a huge hazard
and that's the neighborhood that our
super nice church is in the middle of
that's crazy
and i was one of those as i'm getting
older like through youth group like this
is my church it's my world but then
outside of those gates across the street
i wasn't paying attention to any of that
[ __ ] yeah that was the kind of things
that was really getting in my mind like
do i care about my neighbors and
it drove me out all the way to [ __ ]
iraq to learn how to do that
yeah how to just live my life and love
my neighbors
it's just having a relationship hanging
out with them you're not shoving [ __ ] in
their face
you're not manipulating them it's it's
the best way you know
people people love that preaching aspect
you know without ever getting to know
the community that the person's coming
from
right and this is why there's such a
huge disconnect when people try to
connect with other people because they
think like oh this person doesn't know
these things and i need to teach them a
lesson well it's like first of all
you haven't even done the social human
part of getting to know who they are
because they're not even in a space
willing to accept the things that you're
saying because who the [ __ ] are you to
come in and tell me how to live my life
you know and i think that's why people
always say you have to you have to lead
by example
that's the biggest part like people that
i've seen that have turned to
um like even like a couple of my friends
who were like addicted to drugs or stuff
they didn't stop doing the drugs because
somebody told them to stop
is because they saw somebody else or
they saw something else
that was a life that they wanted yeah it
was by an example that they saw
they saw a possibility exactly this guy
was no different than me
right like david goggins the reason why
i followed david goggs because that guy
was a 300 pound fat [ __ ] right and he
may help me lose weight because i was
like oh
he's he keeps preaching this idea of i
am just like you you know you don't have
to be me but
i was where you're at and you can
accomplish what i did because i'm not a
special human being
you know who that was for me bart bart
quad
because remember when we went to watch
ufc 200 yeah and it didn't show up
so we started watching older fights yeah
yeah yeah yeah so bart was at the studio
and i'm actually standing next to him
we're chilling and watching a fight and
it was
a it was a featherweight belt yeah and
i'm
watching him and you know bart and i
both five
eight nine yeah but he's like he's 80
pounds checked
right so at this point i'm fat as [ __ ]
i'm like 240 250.
yeah but i'm fat and i looked at bar i
was like hey if you were in the ufc what
weight class would you fight in
and you said featherweight uh 145
and at that time what is the 220
something yeah i was like
no way man yeah and then bart looked at
me like he was gonna tear
me apart yeah he's gonna tear me like i
was the biggest [ __ ]
idiot in the world and then he looks at
me and he goes
yes i can i can do it yeah
and i didn't know what to say because i
really immediately that reaction from
him where i felt like i was going to die
was yeah who am i why would i not
believe that parker like look at me i'm
a fat [ __ ]
yeah i said where do you come off saying
that [ __ ] yeah and i really reevaluated
that
and it was from there i was just like i
never believed i can be less than
180 yeah you know and if
at the time and it was literally bart
just looking at me like he was gonna
kill me to make me like
oh i don't believe like in myself
you know round about why i can see why
so many christians
stay fat is because they don't believe
in themselves yeah they have to rely on
jesus and jesus doesn't care if you're
fat or not
you know yeah he's like hey jesus love
you is your family yeah whatever jesus
jesus think are you skinny
yeah he's all right right it's all about
acceptance in that way but sometimes
i think for people like even you and i
like we're we're not easily satiated
yeah right always looking for something
always for looking
for some this big hole and for me
personally
personally you know they always tell you
that
god will fill that jesus shaped hole in
your heart
yeah personally for me i really never
felt
too much of a fulfillment there yeah
especially you know especially when
you're treated like [ __ ]
yeah too the environment you know yeah
and where you have to be like well the
church
doesn't like me and uh the leadership
doesn't like me but
god is still good jesus still likes me
yeah and so i have to walk around like a
wonka like that
like i ain't [ __ ] but jesus still loves
me and i'm just gonna live in
and wallow in in my self-pity or some
[ __ ]
you know and just like at least jesus
but for me to really get to at least
where i want to be like i had to
lift myself up i had to love myself
in a way i think a lot of christians
don't exactly learn how to love
themselves because they have to learn
how jesus loves them and makes them okay
that's who they are and it leaves them
in the dust of all the problems that
they could fix
in their lives because say you know what
i'm okay this way because jesus loves me
maybe you could work on that yeah
anything that happens a lot with
um i think that's also just leadership
and how they kind of misconstrue the
message right because they're trying to
pull out somebody's heartstrings rather
than offer them
real life solutions you know they're
they're saying these
things that they know that these broken
humans want to believe right you know
because if they're like oh
i don't have to fix myself because god
loves me you know when really it's just
that's that was never the case you know
so a lot of the times the message
becomes really misconstrued that's why i
always say you got to find the right
church
you got to find the right church with
like the right message
you know because i i think that would
that was a very korean christian thing
you know but when i started going to
other churches and the message was
different it kind of rocked my world a
little bit
they they helped me evaluate how i
behave and a lot of the things that i do
so sometimes too when people would look
at these these youtube videos right
they're like oh you're it's like you
speak so well but i was like well this
came from a church because i was i was
interested i was a preacher you know i
had to go up and
talk to a bunch of people every week
every [ __ ] week so i had to do this
consistently and um even now when i
don't when i talk about secular [ __ ]
it's it's very christ-like though a lot
of the stuff that i learned was because
of church a lot of my morality
right a lot of how i treat people around
me a lot of how um
maybe even that rebuking part is
probably yeah it's like i'm saying this
with love but [ __ ] you
yeah exactly i just kind of you know did
things my own way
you know yeah obviously for me because i
made a different career choice in a
different career path i decided to stop
doing church stuff but
you know a huge part of who i am and
what i believe and how i behave is
because
of of a protestant christian background
you know dude like
i know i i i don't like to call myself a
christian but i can't stop listening to
christian music
like i keep up with the new releases to
be honest there's a way
there's something about it that makes me
feel about what i loved about church
you know and sometimes i like to get
together to just philosophize with
friends because it makes me
think about the bible study
get-togethers we had and why i like
going out to eat with
my friends is because i i recognize
communion or going off with thai food
community all this other stuff why do we
still go to norway because we love
singing together you know there's all
these things that i have to find
replacements for you
but you know like it's there yeah you
know and it was so heartbreaking to have
to leave church
thinking that i couldn't find that stuff
but it's out there you know one of the
three biggest reasons why
i i switched from going korean churches
too obviously there was like community
issues
was because the music was better
like you have no idea like i hated every
time i went to a church
and there was a guy who just barely knew
how to play the acoustic guitar some
shitty ass electric guitarist and the
shitty [ __ ] drummer
and i you know i loved music and so they
just
nobody could harmonize to save their
[ __ ] lives it was just the wacko [ __ ]
you know why
you know why it's like that at every
korean church because
they strive for mediocrity
because being too good is too prideful
it's a confusion aspect about their
christianity that
doesn't allow themselves to be more
talented learn better perform better
anything they keep throwing themselves
under the bus and just being mediocre
that makes so much sense because when i
was in riverside i joined this youth
group
and i wanted to be a part of the praise
now i hated their music yeah because
they just didn't understand [ __ ]
music yeah you know they didn't unders
like the harmonies that they would put
together like the vocal harmonies we're
[ __ ] trash
it was always this you know it was those
whole notes same whole notes the [ __ ]
esther choice singing the same note
you know what i mean
yeah esther choice and peter kim is
playing this [ __ ] thing and i
remember this dude
like i remember this youth leader too
because i wanted to [ __ ]
[ __ ] him up but he's so lucky that we're
inside of a church
but i remember there was a couple of
things i hated about the church was the
click-like behavior
yeah because i wasn't from the area yeah
i came from uh
sacramento and i joined this praise team
and i remember
i just wanted to i joined the praise
because i had a good voice
way better than his for sure yeah you
know and i wanted to add some stuff i
was like yo let's change the key to this
[ __ ]
you know like you could you could sing
in a higher key and then we'll we'll
work on these few part harmonies and i
wanted to add like
some dope [ __ ] that i learned from the
black churches that i went to right
he wasn't having it he was like no no
this is better right and i remember when
i added stuff and people [ __ ]
loved it they loved my voice they loved
doing this stuff and then this will try
to clown on me he was like oh like you
like doing that extra stuff and he's
like pretending to do runs in front of
my face i just looked at him and i
wasn't laughing
right and he got really quiet and the
only thing i think about is like bro if
we weren't in church
i would i would just roast your ass in
front of this whole [ __ ] church but
he's a church leader so i can't do that
it's like everybody in it happens in
korean churches
yeah they just they give themselves a
ceiling
like of what's acceptable or not
like as if christians can't
have the highest form of skill yeah
like they're not allowed to that's why
when i went to bayside and i heard these
vocal harmonies
you know i'm like and when music is good
that [ __ ] makes you feel god you know so
it was something i never felt going to
these korean churches
because i knew it was going to be a
shitty electric guitar these terrible
singers that are
not terrible but they're very very just
flat they just grew up in church yeah
yeah
these untalented you know they're just
they have they could hold a note
it's really what it is i started hearing
these like these vocal arrangements
these uh
these uh guitar arrangements i'm like
man this is dope
and i wanted to go to praise because
every time i would go to church i would
skip praise yeah because i don't want to
hear this i just want to hear a good
sermon yeah
you know but yeah so i joined the praise
team
at the church i joined when i moved back
to washington
but i was terrible i hadn't played
guitar and sing in a long time i was
terrible so i just stayed off and stuck
on
stuck on the sound board and i just do
the sound every week
instead but towards the end of my time
in washington
i was really really just losing all of
my faith
yeah so i was just like [ __ ] it right i
don't give a [ __ ] about any of this [ __ ]
yeah cause
i honestly my feelings were like i don't
think anybody gives a [ __ ] about me
either
so on my birthday i just went
it was a saturday night i went and got
plastered
just got crazy drunk and i was too drunk
so i
i did a line of coke then i was ready to
drink again
then i was too hyped so i smoked some
weed
and then i was too chill so i started
some more coke and i was thirsty so i
drank more alcohol
and i went wild that night you know and
when i got back to my friend's apartment
he had some e so we crushed it up
and then i snorted some e and i passed
out
like at 4 or 5 am and then i wake up at
like
6 30 and i'm ready to just go to church
now
so there's a thing the last thing i did
was snort e
and i went and passed out and then i
went to church so a couple hours later
i'm
rolling now yeah and i'm at church i'm
doing the sound
and i'm turning up that bass all the way
church
i'm pale and sweaty and after church
everyone's like man ed that sounded
really good today
that was really awesome i was like i was
[ __ ] feeling it [ __ ]
yeah and here's the thing like i went to
them
and i told them like look man i have a
drug problem i'm getting
wasted every weekend i'm doing coke
every weekend
and doing whatever comes my way i'll do
it you know i'm like i'm lost guys
in my small group meetings i'm telling
them this they're like but
is that why the music is so good yeah
it's just like
they're like they start giving you coke
and e they're like well do some more
[ __ ] praise is off the hook dude but
i mean that's where i'm getting to was
just like
they didn't know what to do they're so
grown up in some suburban like christian
like
maybe they're not like a city kind of
church yeah yeah even though they're in
seattle
because they're just disconnected from
everything yeah so
i kept doing it every weekend and i told
them straight up
what i did and after a while they came
out with a new
like contract for worship leaders where
they added a stipulation
no substance abuse i chose not to sign
it i quit and i went and did more drugs
because i felt like nobody gave a [ __ ]
yeah and i told them the last day i'm
quitting guys
um i'm still doing drugs i'm still
suicidal
i really don't know what to do with my
life blah blah and these guys just
looked at me
and had nothing to say now i'm just like
look christian the christian or whatever
human to human i'm
crying i'm telling you you straighten
your face my bron like help me out then
go
all right you guys uh who wants to pray
for edward
these people [ __ ] suck dude like you
honestly you should have
at that point you just gotta find a
better church like that that's so
disappointing because i know
because i know the church that i won't
go to now they would never do that
they would they would go to the ends of
the earth to try to help you out which
is so
because that's what i'm used to now you
know that's my standard now because i
found people who care
that's my standard of a church and they
care more than i give a [ __ ] about them
you know what i mean like they'll
they'll text me like hey have you been i
just want to
hey man [ __ ] leave me alone but at
the same time i'm like don't stop
texting me yeah
because at least it shows you care yeah
you know that you guys will be here if i
need you
you know i'm not gonna say they don't
care they didn't know what to do
they were not equipped for that yeah
which it
led me back to my past trauma about
churches in the first place
like you guys don't know how to do [ __ ]
just to a regular guy
you guys know how to preach the choir
you guys know how to raise sheep that
was born from other sheep
yeah but how are you gonna bring
somebody else in when you're bashing gay
people and all this
other [ __ ] when maybe they want to know
god too yeah ever gave that a thought
you know that's the hard part yeah and
it was yeah there's a whole lot of
reasons like obviously it riles me up
but a lot of the things
that happen like in church in korean
church especially as an older man i get
it
yeah we are all too crazy emotional and
koreans are so passionate koreans are
violent koreans are crazy horny and you
bring that [ __ ] into church you don't
want to try to be holy yeah
and that's a that's just the ball of
chaos yeah
i think if they really actually took
some time to
help each other i don't know help the
less fortunate
than themselves than maintaining a
suburban life
i think it might do them a little better
and for the meantime i'm just kind of
staying out of it now
yeah it's a lot of hurt behind it yeah
it's going to take a while dude
well that wraps up this episode of the
genius brain podcast everybody i hope
you guys enjoyed that episode i mean
listen we just scratched the surface to
be honest with you there's so much more
[ __ ]
but uh that wraps up this episode you
catch ed at ed park
vp on instagram and you'll see him on
this podcast multiple times man because
we're just here
chilling and talking dude so every
thursdays and sundays and we'll see you
guys next time
bye peace